[Music]
[Applause]
get big fast the mantra of amazon.com
and its boisterous founder jeff bezos
from the moment i got there the feeling
was that you just pressed down on the
accelerator harder and harder the
audacious entrepreneur rewrote the rules
of retail there really was this sense of
urgency around this internet land grab
that was taking place you know how do we
establish the amazon brand his strategy
didn't always pay off even after amazon
went public people looked at the
financials and said
this company's not going to make it
amazon.com
was actually
profitable
in december 1995. it must have been for
oh about one hour
with a series of sly moves jeff bezos
built and rebuilt amazon.com if you ask
a question that jeff doesn't feel like
is something they want to go into the
answer you get is going to be the laugh
[Laughter]
and he's laughing all the way to the
back
you can buy anything at amazon.com from
books music shoes and clothing to a
battle tank or a tiki hut
amazon is the most successful online
retailer in the world and still run by
the man who created it back in 1994
jeff bezos
jeff seemed to realize that being
the singular place where a consumer can
find and buy virtually anything that's
available in the retail market was a
critical part of the company's growth
strategy
the public image of jeff bezos is of a
superhero entrepreneur and he is that if
you look at his life from the very
beginning he's taken risks and he's
solved problems and he's created
billions of dollars wealth bezos is more
guarded than his outgoing public persona
and declined to participate in this
program
jeffrey preston bezos was born in
albuquerque new mexico on january
twelfth nineteen sixty four to jackie
guys a seventeen-year-old high school
student
guys divorced his biological father and
married miguel bezos a cuban immigrant
and petroleum engineer for exxon
miguel adopted four-year-old bezos in
1968
bezos described his early computer
experience in a 2001 interview with the
academy of achievement there was a
company in houston that had loaned
excess mainframe computer time
to this little elementary school none of
the teachers knew how to operate this
computer nobody did but there was a
stack of manuals and me and a couple of
other kids stayed after class and
learned how to program this thing
as a teen bezos embarked on his first
serious entrepreneurial effort
a summer camp based out of his house
with an emphasis on science and
literature five students signed up at a
hundred and fifty dollars a pop
in 1986 he graduated from princeton
university summa [ __ ] laude with degrees
in electrical engineering and computer
science nicholas carlson is deputy
editor at businessinsider.com
and has covered amazon for six years
jeff bezos was actually recruited into a
hedge fund named d.e shaw and he didn't
want to work in finance he actually
wanted to work in computer programming
but d e shaw is a computer programmer
and the hedge fund is sort of built
around algorithms and the type of
technology that bezos is interested in
it wasn't the only thing he found
interesting
he came upon a statistic that just
astounded him he saw that the internet
was growing at two thousand three
hundred percent per year and he just
became obsessed with this number
studying the top twenty mail order
businesses bezos saw an opportunity
online
chris anderson is the former
editor-in-chief for wired magazine he
could see that there was this
technological tsunami that was arriving
that was going to disintermediate it was
going to create new distribution
channels reset economics change the way
we bought and sold
and the question was which domain should
we apply it to
the answer was books a commodity for
which no comprehensive catalog existed
in july 1994 he quit his secure wall
street job to pursue his dream
to create one of the world's first
online bookstores
his first investors his parents who he
talked about with the academy of
achievement
my dad's first question was what's the
internet okay so this he wasn't making a
bet on this company or this concept he
was making a bet on his son
in the summer of 1994 jeff bezos and his
wife mackenzie headed to washington
state armed with three hundred thousand
dollars from his parents
entrepreneur and technology expert
esther dyson is chairman of the
investment firm adventure holdings you
now have a lot of people leaving wall
street to go try and do startups but
jeff was different he had a really solid
business wall street background and then
he created something amazing
bezos and his wife settled in bellevue
washington and hired two programmers to
write the code
bezos related the story in a speech at
lake forest college in 1998. i found a
house that could serve as the first
business and it had a garage and seemed
the right thing to do since there's a
history of startups and garages
this
wasn't fully legitimate because it was a
converted enclosed garage but i
considered it somewhat legitimate
because it wasn't insulated those were
not impressive offices he dubbed the
company amazon
after the seemingly endless south
american river with its countless
tributaries
on july 16 1995
amazon.com opened its virtual doors to
the public
james marcus was employee number 55.
marcus was hired to write book reviews
for the site that was nothing more than
a list of titles
when i checked out their site to see if
this was a place where i might want to
work
i discovered it was quite rudimentary
actually there was a front page with an
eclectic mixture of books but the most
notable thing was that there was a huge
catalog of probably several hundred
thousand books at the time but there was
no content in that catalog
the fledgling amazon.com had no
advertising budget
initial sales were generated solely by
word of mouth
heath terry is a managing director at
goldman sachs
there was a lot different about amazon
really from the beginning you know they
weren't in silicon valley they were in
seattle they weren't really into the
whole hype of the bubble they weren't
putting out press releases every single
day
the site caught on within a month books
had been sold to customers in all 50
states and 45 other countries
what was different about amazon was that
jeff ran it right he was organized he
understood distribution he understood
how to
motivate people to buy he just he did
things with great attention to detail
bezos goal for growing the company could
be summed up in a simple line get big
fast was both a mantra and
very much a strategic decision on jeff's
part everything had to be on steroids
all growth had to be on steroids eric
best was manager of business development
at amazon from 1999 to 2001. there
really was this sense of urgency around
capturing e-commerce market share this
internet land grab that was taking place
you know how do we establish the amazon
brand and grow the overall business
at the expense of competitors and within
a very time-bound window
the strategy paid off big time
by the end of 1996 the company reached
15.7 million dollars in sales
the gains were boosted by amazon's
ability to offer tax-free shopping to
most online consumers what makes us
different is vast selection
convenience we deliver right to the
desktop and also the fact that we're the
broadest discounters in the world we
discount over 300 000 titles basically
the best-selling titles that's twice as
many titles as the largest physical
bookstore even offers
but early investors were frustrated the
surge in sales came without profits
while amazon spent millions developing
software and expanding its business you
know there was a lot of risk that was
taken on by the company during those
early days
and i think there was a lot of
speculation around whether or not that
was the right thing to do it's easy now
to look back and say of course amazon
needed that capital and they needed to
invest at the rate that they did in
order to achieve the scale that they now
have that was not always clear from day
one
what was clear was that bezos was
unstoppable
he kept up the pace and powered ahead
for amazon's ipo
the idea was that you could not rest on
your laurels for one moment and that you
just had to keep innovating all the time
and staying out of the competition all
the time and never have even a
millisecond of complacency
[Music]
on may 15 1997 the stock began trading
on the nasdaq stock market at 29.25
cents a share nearly 12 higher than its
offering price the day of the actual ipo
was a very big deal there were you know
parties all over the company and jeff
addressed us you know over the speaker
phone from new york i mean jeff was
telling us on the phone you know we've
made history today you have all made
history today it was pretty damn
exciting
but despite the well-received ipo tech
analysts still offered a dollar
assessment of the company
tim o'reilly is founder and ceo of
o'reilly media most people remember the
business stories that amazon was going
to be toast people were scrutinizing
their financials they were saying this
company will never be profitable or
there were a lot of naysayers
the company's engineers were hard at
work updating the site introducing
features like one-click shopping
by the end of 1997 the value of amazon
stock nearly tripled jeff would say to
us do not pay attention to the stock
price
he was very confident that in the long
run it would go up and up and up but
felt it was very dangerous to
look at it in the short run
amazon continued their frantic expansion
hiring more than 7 000 employees and
beefing up their product line you know
we just heard talk about virtually
everything and anything we could sell
groceries health care cell phone plans
and cell phones magazines and then
eventually you know hardware garden
hoses and toys
the expanded product line and high
volume sales paid off for both
amazon.com and bezos
on december 20th 1999 he was anointed
time magazine's person of the year made
my mom cry and uh you know parents are
always proud and that feels great it was
the ultimate legitimization of his sort
of starry-eyed dream of conquering the
world through e-commerce like you flip
to the inside of the magazine there's
jeff dressed as indiana jones swinging
on a vine
it was kind of making him into an
american folk hero in a way it's like
you suddenly like paul bunyan was in the
office down the hall from you
bezos was at the top of his game
but an industry-wide disaster was right
around the corner
by the late 90s amazon.com was an online
juggernaut
but in 2000 the dot-com bubble burst
stock prices slumped and jeff bezos was
forced to take drastic measures
there were at least two waves of layoffs
and as is usually the case with these
things you don't know who's going to go
you kind of cower in your office and
wait for the hr person to you know
summon you with a finger
and it feels bad to see your your
colleagues go in the context of the
slowing economy and the uh the deep
slowing and consumer confidence this was
the only prudent decision that we could
make
by september 2001 the company's stock
hit an all-time low and bottomed out at
5.97 cents a share
from poster child to whipping boy in
nanoseconds it's not the kind of stock
that you can own and sleep well if
you're a small investor and i think by
the way that's true of all internet
stocks the advantage that amazon had was
they had built this war chest so to
speak on their their balance sheet of
cash to to fund them through all this
jeff bezos made a lot of large bets and
not all of them paid off the company
didn't profit for many years in the
beginning the reason jeff bezos got away
with that and benefited long term is
because he was always very direct with
employees and stakeholders in the
company
at long last by january 2002 those bets
began to pay off
amazon's stock price rebounded and bezos
company did something it hadn't done in
seven years posted a profit
the best thing could say about him is
that he was unwavering in his confidence
he could see the bigger picture and he
knew that the skeptics were
were short-termers they were not seeing
the big picture and he stuck to the
vision once the bubble burst the
investors patience
for companies saying we're going to make
big investments and building out a dot
com side to our business
was very very thin and so amazon took
advantage of that and started partnering
with target and toys r us and the gap
and other traditional retailers the dot
com retail giant joined forces with more
than 400 companies but not all retailers
were willing partners i do know of a
number of cases in which
he has acquired companies in order to
take out competitors potential future
competitors rather than because he
actually wants that business to continue
with his company back on track bezos
switched gears and increased his focus
on a much different passion
on march 6 2003 he charted a helicopter
to scout property in a remote region of
southwest texas
he was looking to buy up ranches for a
venture he had started in 2000 called
blue origin
blue origin is a technology company
whose purpose was to develop vertical
takeoff and vertical landing rockets for
human space travel
the trip was nearly a disaster
shortly after takeoff the helicopter
flipped and landed in a riverbed
in 2003 jeff bezos almost died in a
helicopter crash
it's sort of a pattern where he can go
through something difficult like a
dot-com crash be philosophical about it
laughing off with this big famous laugh
unlike space exploration ventures
bankrolled by private backers including
elon musk richard branson and john
carmack
bezos is obsessive about keeping his
efforts at blue origin secret
for a variety of reasons it's pretty
secretive and i think actually from the
point of view of the space industry
that's sort of a pity what makes
a good market is when you have a bunch
of competitors
openly competing and they try and
position themselves against one another
and the market's visible they compete
for money they compete for people and so
forth
after six years of working behind closed
doors and locked gates blue origin's
odd-looking test rocket blasted off
[Applause]
bezos was also set to launch on another
revolutionary effort this one closer to
home this is an opportunity to
hugely expand the book industry expand
pricing expand the definition of what a
book could be but it required someone
with sufficient clout to do that
end-to-end hardware software web
integration and only amazon was in a
position to do that
on november 19 2007 jeff bezos took to
the charlie rose show to announce the
release of a groundbreaking new product
here in my hands is what we're talking
about it is called the kindle tell me
when you first had the idea
that this might be possible what we
realized at the time
was that there were a few technologies
that were sort of converging that we
could combine together at the right
recipe and make something that would be
what we hoped would be transformative in
the world of electronic reading
the kindle was an instant hit amazon put
this device out there that takes away so
many of the aesthetic pleasures that
people take in books you know you can't
smell the pages anymore dog ear the
books but it turns out book lovers who
are all these people that feared and
load this thing now they love the kindle
the 399
sold out nationwide in just five and a
half hours
the number of kindles sold however
remains a closely guarded secret a
company spokesman said that they choose
not to disclose the number
jane friedman is former ceo of
harpercollins and co-founder of open
road integrated media no one today knows
how many kindles there really are out
there it's a guessing game we know that
there are millions but how many millions
but it's strategic for amazon obviously
because that's what they do they keep a
lot of information close to the vest
but publishers saw the kindle as an
industry killer there will be a real
blood on the tracks of publishing in the
next few years because publishers did
not wake up soon enough to the fact that
amazon was a competitor
[Music]
while the kindle was making serious
waves in the e-book marketplace amazon
was preparing to make its largest
corporate acquisition to date
tony shea is ceo of zappos.com america's
leading online shoe retailer when i
first met jeff bezos in 2004 he had
contacted us and said they were
interested in possibly acquiring zappos
at the time we said we weren't
interested because zappos would kind of
lose its identity
shea was hesitant to sell to amazon they
contacted us again and said they were
willing to consider a different scenario
where we could remain independent
and we started realizing
wow they might actually
be really great partners
amazon purchased the hot online shoe
retailer in the summer of 2009.
zappos investors received 10 million
amazon shares worth about 1.2 billion
dollars at the time the deal closed they
got stock which at this point is better
than cash and what this kind of shows is
that jeff bezos and amazon is someone
who yes he can steamroll the competition
when he needs to but he's also willing
to play ball and negotiate and get what
he wants but
make everybody wealthier in the process
the shoe fit but his cash cow the kindle
was about to get some very serious
competition from a tech giant and we
call it
the ipad
on january 27
2010 apple launched the ipad also
designed for use as an electronic
reading device bezos responded
aggressively by cutting costs and adding
new features to his e-reader one thing
that bezos has always been comfortable
doing running amazon is playing with
very tight margins so when you see the
kindle lowering in price what you're
seeing is bezos recognizing what the
real long-term gain here for amazon is
to be the place where everyone buys all
of their ebooks and the kindle is just
how they get them
the phenomenal growth of the e-book
market devastated bricks and mortar
stores
amazon came on the scene and became a
competitor to the bricks and mortar
retailers and they were the e-tailer
everybody was coexisting in fact borders
and it may have been their downfall but
borders did all of their digital
their digital selling through amazon had
borders established its own
presence it might have been a very
different situation today
according to the authors guild amazon
had been buying books from publishers at
12 to 13 wholesale and selling them as
kindle books for 9.99 taking a loss each
time
best-selling author john grisham railed
against amazon's pricing model we're
going to get to a point if a book is
worth ten dollars okay
whether it's a discounted hardback at
amazon or an ebook sold by amazon for
the kindle if we're ten dollars okay
then suddenly the whole industry is
going to change you're going to lose
publishers you're going to lose
bookstores others saw opportunity you
look at all of the authors that have
been kind of empowered by
kendall to develop a direct consumer
relationship that they never had before
and i think that's where amazon is able
to come out a winner in all of this by
building this bridge between authors and
their readers that in the past has never
really existed
borders books filed for bankruptcy and
barnes and noble the largest bookstore
chain has been struggling
in 2011
amazon.com stepped beyond the retail
sales market and into the video
streaming ring going head-to-head with
netflix andrew wallenstein is a tv
editor for variety magazine i think if
you're netflix you're looking at amazon
and really sizing them up as a
competitor amazon has a lot of traction
online they've got deep pockets to buy
just as much content they're at the very
beginning of this kind of effort but in
time amazon could grow to be just as big
as netflix
the e-commerce retail giant is also
fending off growing efforts to put an
end to its untaxed online sales
several states now require amazon to
charge local sales tax
but bezos remains cool under fire and
unfazed he continues to forge ahead now
jeff bezos has his fingers in
everybody's pie he's got video streaming
which competes with netflix he's doing
music now which competes with apple and
itunes he's even selling android apps in
an amazon.com app store that goes right
after google's marketplace if he sees
something where amazon can make a little
piece of money and help its margins
which are you know so thin he'll go for
it
going forward has gotten him this far
his space project is going even farther
in april 2011 nasa awarded blue origin
22 million dollars to continue
developing its space vehicle design
he was listed by bloomberg as the 20th
richest person in the world with a net
worth estimated at 25 billion dollars
amazon.com remains the world's largest
online retailer he's not just a
visionary with visions he's an architect
with blueprints and some notion of how
to make things work he thinks very
carefully about design and structure and
operations
and that's what turns a visionary into
somebody who actually accomplishes
something
he could have sold amazon to barnes
noble or probably to some other
booksellers and walked away with many
millions of dollars like in his early
30s since then
he just keeps on coming up with really
good ideas
he's not
the hard charging going to take no
prisoners type ceo
he's somebody that has his vision for
how he wants to build this company and
is able to surround himself by people
that buy into that i think ultimately
that's one of the reasons that he's been
as successful as he has
[Music]
reid hastings seems as tough as his dvds
practically indestructible
he has transformed the world of movies
tv and cable twice we rent dvds it's a
flat price it's really easy he's one of
the people that killed the video store
oh we would have liked nothing better
than to bury netflix he defied his
critics and bet his company on movies by
mail when dvds were a novelty most
investors were just convinced netflix
was just another.com it was a you know a
nichey little idea people didn't want a
subscription and it would never take off
it took off and flew high for 12 years
its value climbing to 12 billion
before a spectacular stumble stalled its
growth netflix subscribers are fleeing
on mass more than 800 000 customers
canceled their service last quarter i've
heard some people say that it feels like
aliens have taken over his body hastings
is determined to restore his company's
reputation and his own he comes across
as sort of a typical silicon valley
executive very low key but you know he's
one of those guys who has to win
10 12 years ago when we started netflix
you know the internet was still aol dial
up but realize wow networks are just
going to grow and you know what's going
to happen
all video is going to become click and
watch internet video everything
reid hastings has made a career out of
anticipating the future
first in a software tool then with the
simple dvd and a 32 cent stamp you won't
find anybody who has more drive than
reed hastings he's always thinking about
the strategic shifts that need to be
made he is an incredibly focused
innovative individual
that is like smart
like light years smart he's one of those
guys who doesn't like to talk about
himself a lot but who really feels like
his actions show
you know how good a company
he can run
true to form he declined to talk about
himself for this program as well
hastings was born in boston
massachusetts in 1960 and grew up in the
suburb of belmont former governor gray
davis is a friend of hastings he came
from a middle class background his
father was a lawyer did not come from
great wealth
education is the reason he's successful
educational success included a
bachelor's degree from bowdoin college
in maine
he spent one summer in a training
program for the u.s marines but realized
the military wasn't for him instead he
joined the peace corps where he taught
for two years then hitchhiked across
africa with 10 bucks in his pocket
teaching was inspiring as he told
charlie rose in this 2005 conversation
well i was a high school math teacher
originally out of college um in the
peace corps uh in swaziland um and i
love teaching i love i taught high
school math and it was just a fantastic
experience
returning to the us he got a masters in
computer science at stanford and landed
a job at a technology company called
adaptive corporation mark box is a
startup investor who was introduced to
hastings at the dawn of a new era in
computer programming he said you know up
until this time every program that's
been created
has been created in the head essentially
of one person but now we're kind of
getting to the point where
it takes two three five ten guys to
write a program and so as that starts to
happen
you have problems coordinating between
the people and that creates lots of
errors errors hastings thought he could
fix he wrote a program and started a
company with markbox called pure
software
like all perfectionists hastings wanted
to hire the best and quietly did
whatever it took to get them
aki fujimora was then an experienced
software manager at cadence design
systems i didn't want to leave the
company that i was with but then
he came over to my apartment with a six
pack of beer and uh we started talking
and
that's his typical style audrey mclean
was one of hastings first investors and
a board member once we got going there
was no stopping it the company
doubled year over year for four years in
a row so it was an absolute rocketship
by 1995 pure software had reached the
holy grail of 90 startups going public
on opening day the stock shot up 75
it was a very exciting ipo in fact we
were the most successful ipo of the year
in 1995 for one week the following week
netscape went public and they eclipsed
it the success landed hastings on the
front page of usa today in front of his
flashy new porsche carrera a photo he
would come to regret
cliff edwards is a technology writer for
bloomberg businessweek i think he felt
like it sort of portrayed him as a sort
of rich whiz kid living the dream when
in fact he really wanted to show that
here's a company that he is nursing
uh to health and and is is pouring his
life into two years later he sold the
company for 750 million dollars and
turned his talents in a very different
direction michael kirst is a professor
emeritus of education at stanford
university i got a call from somebody i
never heard of named reid hastings
saying he wanted to come to stanford and
study state education policy and
politics and i wasn't quite sure why
he was interested in this because it
didn't fit in with anything on his
resume
for hastings it was a new start
for six months he studied hard then went
to the state capitol to advocate for a
new kind of school in california and he
was able to successfully create one of
the first laws and charter schools in
the country so it allowed innovation and
new operators to come in
and was really an entirely new concept
for california
[Music]
there was a new concept for hastings as
well
a familiar annoyance prompted reed
hastings to reinvent an industry in
1997.
he recalled getting a 40 late fee for a
movie rental in this 2005 appearance on
charlie rose i remember i didn't want to
tell my wife about it
and i thought oh great now i'm kind of
compromising the integrity of my
marriage over this late fee so of course
i did tell her about it but
um it made me think i can't be the only
one who is struggling with this late fee
thing and
just started me thinking about the
internet and dvds um and
how something could work without late
fees the movie rental industry made
around eight billion dollars a year
nearly all of it from the dominant
format of the day vhs cassettes hastings
saw the opportunity in a new format and
a surprising new business dvds by mail
but first he had to find out if the
discs could survive the us mail so i
stuffed a bunch of cds and they couldn't
buy dvds then put them mailed them to
myself
and then i had to wait for 24 hours to
see him come home uh to see are they
going to be all shattered in a bits
along with the my idea uh and then you
know the next day three o'clock the
postman arrives and rip open the
envelopes and the first one's in good
shape the second one's in good shape and
the third one's a good shape but i'm
like this sucker is gonna work
in 1998 hastings launched netflix as the
first online store to rent dvds current
redbox president mitch lowe was a
co-founder we started in an old bank
building in fact our inventory was in
the old vault there was about seven or
eight people everybody was dedicated to
figuring out how to do something
disruptive in the entertainment
distribution business
they stocked up on dvds from retailers
like best buy but there was a problem
less than one in a hundred households
owned a dvd player
they cost nearly six hundred dollars and
no one knew when they'd become more
affordable he committed everything to
dvds if dvds didn't happen he's got not
you know the company's nothing it's zero
[Music]
blockbuster and hollywood video
dominated the industry with thousands of
retail stores in almost every
neighborhood
if hastings wanted to compete he had to
build a better customer experience
so he innovated with an idea an easy to
use subscription service for a monthly
fee members were allowed as many movies
as they could watch with no late fees he
realized
having to resell the customer every time
is bad idea on a three dollar
transaction and he eventually got the
company to go to the subscription model
and i think that changed everything for
him that change was boosted by two
popular features the queue a list of
movies that the user wanted and computer
generated recommendations that were
surprisingly accurate michael pachter
has followed netflix for 10 years as a
research analyst with web bush
securities the internet ordering
mechanism and interface was innovative
the recommendation engine was innovative
and the queue was innovative and i think
where netflix really thrived early on
was they were first to figure all this
stuff out
but for all their innovation netflix was
still barely on the radar
their revenues of 5 million at the start
of 2000 vanished next to blockbuster's
4.5 billion
900 times the size of netflix
in a bold and clever move hastings went
for help to his biggest competitor
everybody loved blockbuster and
blockbuster was the golden child and
netflix was sort of this ugly step child
that was coming up and everybody thought
well this thing's not going to last it's
not going to have legs it's going to die
we were having challenges as far as
acquiring customers and we saw
blockbuster as the greatest single
source for rental customers so we
actually reached out to blockbuster and
invited them to become a strategic
partner
and and an investor blockbuster the
entertainment giant found it
entertaining
john antiocho had been blockbuster's ceo
for three years when netflix came
calling we thought well if we're going
to get in this business we probably
shouldn't give the
internet rights to another company for
a couple percentage points and that's
what caused us to keep
evaluating whether we wanted to enter
the business or not i think that you
know netflix was
was very lucky that blockbuster which
who was the sleeping giant at the time
didn't do anything
they stayed asleep
because reed is a gentleman i think if
you had a different ceo at netflix who
was a little bit cockier and a little
bit more brash
i think that blockbuster might have been
provoked into competing
there didn't seem much reason to compete
by the end of 2000 netflix was
hemorrhaging money their is skyrocketed
to 57 million dollars it just sounded
like another dot-com idea you know like
e-toys and most investors were just
convinced netflix was you know a niche
little idea people didn't want a
subscription and it would never take off
while netflix was struggling to become
profitable in 2000 reed hastings did the
unexpected again
he took an additional job on
california's state board of education
any of you have tried to change large
organizations know that half the battle
is getting it on the right course the
second half of the battle is keeping it
on that course he was appointed by then
governor gray davis you know if i was
ever in a foxhole i would like reid
hastings with me because we would have
discussions about the next school board
meeting and we would argue over what
that decision would should be but once
you know we've kind of came to a
decision
he went in there and he held his ground
and he got the reforms established
netflix on the other hand was anything
but established and heading into the dot
com dive how the mighty have fallen
according to a recent study by morgan
stanley dean witter the average internet
stock is down two-thirds from its
52-week high
having long planned to go public netflix
filed preliminary papers as the market
spiraled down we faced a lot of
obstacles in the first ipo attempt the
bubble had burst uh there was the belief
that the business that internet
businesses had no substance behind them
uh there was the anthrax scare there was
9 11. it was just like the perfect storm
of everything going in the wrong
direction
hastings canceled the ipo
in october 2001 netflix had to lay off a
third of the company netflix was on the
brink of disaster
i think that between
1999 and 2002 netflix could have
gone under at any time had serious
competition arisen
as the year was closing hastings got the
break he needed the price of dvd players
plunged
and hastings slipped a coupon for a free
trial of netflix in nearly every new box
business took off
[Music]
with the company back on track the much
delayed ipo became a reality
in 2002 netflix went public
the stock rose 12 the first day to 16.75
but it was a double-edged sword keith
terry tracks netflix as the managing
director of internet research at
canaccord genuity going public got them
a lot of attention not just from
consumers but also come from competitors
and so they were going to start seeing
pretty significant competition from
companies like walmart and entrenched
players like blockbuster
walmart launched its competing service
in 2003 a year later blockbuster also
jumped in we initially launched kind of
the same way netflix did which is free
trial membership
you know one of the most beautiful words
in the you know american language is
free and that was getting us reasonable
growth
blockbuster's monthly fee was also two
dollars less than netflix
igniting a nasty price war
netflix slashed its price
blockbuster countered
walmart edged under both so blockbuster
cut to rock bottom
in a conference call on the end of the
year earnings hastings declared
blockbuster has thrown everything but
the kitchen sink at us quite frankly
myself and a couple of key members of
our management team were sitting in my
office listening to the conference call
someone said well
why don't we send him a kitchen sink i
said
good idea next day we shipped one out at
that point the rivalry was definitely
established
the fierce competition on multiple
fronts took its toll netflix stock
plunged 75 percent
analyst michael pachter commented that
netflix is a worthless piece of crap
with really nice people running i was
convinced that blockbuster would compete
effectively and so it seemed to me that
if blockbuster was determined to retain
its customers the netflix would
disappear
hastings wasn't going down without a
fight
he sacrificed profits to drive back the
competition and maintain the company's
growth
it became a war of attrition the view
that you had out there was that netflix
wasn't going to be able to survive uh
this this level of competition from a
lot of people and that blockbuster and
then walmart were ultimately just going
to squeeze the profits out of netflix
and i think what both companies found in
pretty short order was this business was
a lot harder than they thought
while the battle with blockbuster and
walmart raged reed hastings suffered a
personal setback for four years hastings
had championed public school reform on
california's state board of education
but when he pushed for more english and
bilingual programs he was pushed out by
democratic representatives it was a blow
to him and it was surprising and it was
i would think somewhat even humiliating
to be turned down by your own political
party
but he said if this is the issue that
you want to kick me off the state board
about then i go proudly with my head
held high
hastings focused his attention on his
company's battle for the dvd by mail
business and in the middle of 2005 the
tide began to turn
walmart pulled out giving netflix their
rental customers in exchange for
promoting their sales
blockbuster was gaining subscribers but
losing hundreds of millions of dollars
now it was hastings turn to call someone
nice we're not against blockbuster
they're all nice people but our goal is
to offer a better service that consumers
prefer us to them and that eventually
that does result in them closing
in 2007 at the sundance film festival in
utah antiocho said he was called to a
private summit with hastings to explore
the possibility of a deal his preference
would have been for netflix to buy
blockbuster online and what we proposed
back was a merger it never got beyond
talks because of concerns about
antitrust regulations
by 2008 antiocho was gone and
blockbuster backed away from its online
business they lost hundreds of millions
of dollars trying to compete with
netflix and they just didn't have the
cash to keep up competing at the level
and you knew at some point they were
going to have to give up and ultimately
that's what happened
it was a triumph for netflix
but no sooner had hastings secured the
movie by mail business then he launched
a new service that would mean the demise
of the dvd
netflix delivered its billionth dvd in
2007.
hastings was about to reinvent his
company with a service that promised to
make dvd by mail obsolete
streaming video online
it was what he had foreseen from the
very beginning of netflix it just took a
decade to arrive if there's anything you
would want to bank on it's the
technology will keep making bandwidth
faster and cheaper
bandwidth may have been cheaper but not
the shows themselves
unlike dvds netflix needed a license for
every movie it streamed and fees were
astronomical andrew wallenstein is an
editor for the hollywood news daily
variety i think the kind of titles
netflix first started out with streaming
was probably the bottom of the barrel it
was kind of the the movies or tv
programs that were long forgotten not
the best stuff i remember making you
know a mocking comment in a research
note
about how
no one wanted to see revenge of the
nerds 3 when it was a new movie back in
you know the early 90s so they certainly
didn't want to see it in 2007
even if they did netflix could only
stream to one device the personal
computer we don't watch movies on our pc
he's gonna stream to the pc
who cares and we thought it was nuts we
really thought he was nuts so hastings
offered the new service to subscribers
for nothing and when he then announced
and we're going to provide this for free
we were sure he was nuts
[Music]
he pursued even more content adding
eleven thousand titles in less than two
years and finally he secured a
breakthrough deal for first run movies
and shows i think you have to go back a
few years to the deal that they struck
with stars which enabled them to get
some great films out of the sony library
the disney library and they only made
that deal for something like 20 million
dollars which in retrospect was the
steel of the decade
deals followed with many of the major
studios
and it's my pleasure to introduce
netflix ceo reed hastings
more impressive was how rapidly netflix
expanded the world of streaming to geek
gadgets the ipad has been a tremendous
success for us and almost every
entertainment system on the planet
content and access drove phenomenal
growth
by 2011 subscribers hit 20 million
topping 2 billion dollars in revenue had
grabbed the attention of industry
goliaths amazon apple google and
facebook they're all 800 pound gorillas
and this is sort of the danger point for
netflix if you're thinking of any time
where they may
have faced more pressure i can't think
of one surprisingly the real pressure
for netflix didn't come from those other
tech giants but from a series of
spectacular self-inflicted wounds in
july 2011 netflix announced that it was
raising its monthly subscription fee
sixty percent
eight hundred thousand subscribers
defected
two months later a contrite hastings
apologized we're making this video today
to apologize in person he went on to
announce that netflix would split its
dvd and streaming businesses the price
increase remained but dvd by mail would
become a new brand quickster
the move fell flat
customers and shareholders continue to
flee dumping subscriptions and stock
netflix now in a downward spiral was
forced to backtrack
netflix pushing the rewind button today
the company coming out with a big
flip-flop saying that quickster is dead
and that the dvd and streaming services
are back under one umbrella now the
reason for the reversal is simple
customers just didn't like it hastings
delivered yet another apology this time
for moving too quickly quickster became
the symbol of uh netflix not listening
and we quickly um change course on that
and we're going to stick with dvd as
part of the netflix brand it was an epic
collapse netflix lost almost two-thirds
of its value in three months including a
stunning 2.3 billion in one day and if
that wasn't enough bad news netflix and
stars parted ways depriving netflix from
newer films from disney and sony leaving
the impression that netflix was losing
content as it raised prices hastings
moved quickly and announced new content
deals with dreamworks animation
relativity amc cw and others
despite the stumbles hastings says he
never considered stepping down
he said he wants to be measured by the
success of 12 years rather than the
mistakes of 12 weeks i think reed has
changed the way
we all think about consuming
entertainment he's expanded the options
and the way you get movies i would not
count out reid hastings and netflix i
think again that they
are a company that
knows their challenges
that they don't hide from them there's
very few companies that have done this
many things and succeeded and you know
12 years later you know again it's one
of those companies where you may not
like the company but you can't argue
about its successes
[Music]
richard branson the man with the golden
touch and the billionaire smile
he's fabulously rich famous as a rock
star and he always seems to be having a
really good time
i've been extraordinarily fortunate i've
enjoyed every minute of my life i
wouldn't swap my life with anybody
he's not impressed by wealth he's more
bored about do i have fun and don't have
excitement you gotta have the balance
branson parlayed a sexy name virgin into
branding gold
an astounding 300 plus goods and
services from rock to air travel to cell
phones to trains we have taken on the
big fat bloated companies that have not
really thought too much about the
consumer and we've gone in and shaken
them up if you'd analyze the risks that
richard was taking wouldn't take him
because no risk analysis would say go
ahead with this
to keep it all afloat branson became his
own best pitch man
living out the virgin values of
adventure and fun even if it meant
putting his own life on the line
i do seem to have conceived almost every
way known to man to try to kill myself
and i've been very fortunate to be here
today to talk about some of these
stories if such a title actually existed
richard branson might really be the most
interesting man in the world
he owns his own island balloons around
the globe
works with world leaders and he plans to
take a virgin submarine to the uncharted
bottom of the ocean floor
his riskiest adventure yet you only live
once and we accept that there are risks
attached to
doing something that mankind hasn't done
before but we go we go there with our
eyes open
branson has spent much of his life on
the high wire of entrepreneurial risk
he has amassed a personal fortune of
more than four billion dollars don't be
bad
i've never been interested in
making money i mean it um easy to say i
suppose people might say when you have
made money but i i've just been
interested in creating things and
creating things that i could be proud of
and
and you know having a lot of fun
creating things
richard charles nicholas branson was
born on july 18 1950 to middle class
parents on the outskirts of london his
father was a barrister his mother was a
former flight attendant
severely dyslexic he could barely read
by the age of eight and was hopelessly
lost with numbers
school was painful you know i'd look at
look at a blackboard and wouldn't be
able to understand anything that was
going on
interestingly if you look at the history
of dyslexics they they often
exceed quite exceptionally because they
concentrate on the areas that they that
they're good at it's certainly taught
the art of delegation from quite a young
age
nick powell was branson's closest friend
and future business partner i always
thought with richard that
he was going to make an impact on the
world you could tell
from a relatively early age that he had
qualities that were not common amongst
all the other friends that that we had
we used to play dare sitting on either
side of the white line
and it was the last one a move when the
car came down the road richard always
won the games of dare
but branson had a strong entrepreneurial
streak
when he was 13 he tried growing
christmas trees for sale he tried
breeding parakeets
at 15 he decided to launch a national
student newspaper i worked out of a
phone box at my school ringing up
coca-cola ringing up you know people to
try to write for the magazine ringing up
barclays bank to try to get them to
advertise you know the queues of people
outside the phone boxes i was shoving
more money into the into the phone
the magazine student was an instant hit
with a circulation of 50 000.
graham boyton is a former travel
reporter for the london telegraph and
covered branson for over 20 years
although he was a child of the 60s he
was always slightly awkward so i think
what happened was the business gave a
vocabulary a raise on debt and and
that's and he and he went from there
in 1970 branson started a mail order
discount record company that he hoped
would raise money for the magazine the
first order of business was coming up
with a name
somebody suggested slip disk records we
had the you know the old vinyl disc
which kept on slipping and somebody else
laughed you know why not virgin we're
all virgins and hysterical after all all
around
um and
and i suddenly thought i am virgin at
business um you know i might be a virgin
at other things as well and you know why
not virgin
a postal strike in 1971 nearly
deflowered the mail order record
business
so branson decided to open a record
store one with headphones and water
pillows that catered to a younger
generation
simon draper branson's cousin was his
first record buyer and the future head
of virgin records everyone was paid the
same so this there was just a kind of a
feeling that no one should be earning
any more money than anyone else but if
you stopped to think about it it was
actually convenient to have everyone
paid the same because it could pay
everyone less some of the people who
worked for richard in the record shops
in
in notting hill
they used to steal the records out of
the shops and they were absolutely
amazed when richard fired them
for for stealing he was wired to be a
businessman from from day one
five months after opening the virgin
store branson was suddenly arrested for
tax evasion
he was discounting his records in part
because he had figured out a way to get
around a 33 percent record tax
he spent a night in jail and his parents
had to put up their home to get him out
he thought that the part of getting in
last game was to avoid paying tax and i
think that must have come as a huge
shock to richard he was extremely upset
but he behaved impeccably he carried the
can so no one else
had any penalties
i had managed to avoid a criminal
offence by paying what the customs and
exercise needed and we expanded our
record shops very quickly so we could
get the turnover in order to pay you
know pay off the debt since then i've
made sure that we've done everything
ethically and you know without without
worry that someone's going to come
knocking on our door
to pay off a 150 000 fine and avoid
going to court and possibly prison
branson rolled the dice on some new
ventures including a recording studio
and a new record label which he launched
with his cousin simon draper
their first signing was an unknown folky
named mike oldfield with an odd
instrumental album called tubular bells
[Music]
well we're asking each other to take a
punt at what we thought it was going to
sell and i seem to think that i thought
it would sell 20 000 copies which seemed
a lot to me
at the time
but millions later you know very
different story 16 million to be precise
overnight the record put virgin on the
map
and made richard branson not yet 23 a
millionaire branson poured his profits
into new artists and ventures but his
willingness to reinvest all his winnings
unnerved his partners nick powell put up
so much resistance that branson bought
him out i didn't believe we had enough
cash flow to sustain the expansion of
the company
and i was wrong
i'm willing to double down
maybe more than i recommend to other
people
there have been occasions where i've got
my wife to sign this bit of paper and
she hasn't realized that the house has
been put on on the line for the next
business venture
by 1984 richard branson was living the
life of a rock and roll kingpin he owned
this island in what else the british
virgin islands
and virgin records was one of the most
successful independent labels in the
world the sex pistols
simple minds
human league culture club were all
million selling acts
branson was flush with cash and looking
for ways to spend it
out of the blue an insurance lawyer
named randolph fields called and asked
branson to back him on a transatlantic
airline simon draper and my other poor
partners would be tearing their hair out
because
you know suddenly you know i was saying
you know i hate traveling on other
people's airlines and we can do it
better my shares
um which i owned at that time 15 of the
whole virgin group um were becoming
pretty valuable
so i was appalled and i said
this is the beginning of the end of our
relationship
branson launched his airline with a
single used 747 that he leased from
boeing the guy from boeing said
you know what did you say the name of
your company was i said well virgin
um you know we're the people that
brought you the sex whistles the rolling
stones he just
slightly jokingly said well
you know with a name like that you know
we hope your airline will go the whole
way
um and
you know we'll we'll give it a go
after buying fields out of the
partnership branson decided to offer an
upgraded mix of economy and business
class fares with a big emphasis on
non-stop fun
[Music]
virgin's inaugural flight from london to
new york set the tone
let me tell you it was a baccanalion
orgy i mean it was wild there was
drinking there were topless models on
the plane it was out of a party and
richard led from the front
david tate the first person branson
hired was an executive with virgin
atlantic when the daughter of the
airplane opened at newark it was kind of
like a champagne cork coming out of a
bottle because to this day i think there
was still a record number of champagne
bottles drunk on that flight over
with just one plane and one route
branson's first problem was promotion he
didn't have the advertising budget to
compete with british airways and the
other giant carriers so he took matters
into his own hands
embarking on a series of breathless
ballooning and boating adventures that
would quickly turn virgin airlines into
a household name this is the beginning
of a great adventure
his 1987 flight across the atlantic
fascinated world media for weeks
five people had died in earlier attempts
pair lindstrand was branson's co-pilot
he would entirely put his life in my
hands and
i must see his houseguards
[Music]
as they eased the balloon into the irish
sea fierce winds tossed them against the
waves
my fellow blueness and the more
experienced blueness jumped jumped out
of the balloon
i was left in this balloon on my own
and the balloon spiraled up to
10 15 000 feet
if i'm in the water rich is in the
balloon he doesn't really know how it
works
that was scariest moment in my life
branson managed to lower the balloon and
jumped into the freezing water
a royal air force helicopter fished him
out along with pair who nearly died
after swimming in place for two hours
i used to like to describe richard as a
cross between evil knievel and ted
turner
he'll always tell you that i'm
ballooning because it's great publicity
for the company baloney he's doing it
because he enjoys it
if he were a cat he'd be on his third
set of nine lives
by the end of 1989 richard branson's
world was expanding on all fronts he
married his long time partner joan
templeman in a ceremony on necker island
the couple already had two kids
four-year-old sam and eight-year-old
holly
the company was also branching out
branson had taken the virgin group
public in 1986 with an ipo that
generated more than 56 million dollars
i don't think going public will make
that big a difference um to the way we
conduct our business
that turned out to be wrong
it did make a difference
branson chaffed had been accountable to
an outside board and bought back virgin
after two years he now presided over a
small but precarious empire with a
growing airline that was in constant
danger of going under
and worse british airways was determined
to crush its upstart rival
the rivalry between british airways and
virgin atlantic has always puzzled me i
think it was down to british
establishment seeing this young upstart
with long hair sort of reckless
motor mouse airline entrepreneur and it
really cheesed them off so much so that
in 1991
british airways launched what the press
called the dirty tricks campaign they
had teams of people
you know behind closed doors illegally
accessing our computer information
ringing our passengers pretending to be
from virgin atlantic saying we had you
know flights that were cancelled and
switching them onto british airways they
had people going through my rubbish bins
going through the rubbish bins of our
clubs um you know trying to
uh you know pick up any any kind of dirt
on us you know they were placing stories
in the press and so on and so on most
damagingly branson was convinced that
british airways was stoking rumors that
virgin was insolvent and about to go
under
will whitehorn is the former head of
virgin galactic and has worked closely
with branson since 1987. every day you
take off if you've got empty seats
you've lost money
so if somebody can persuade passengers
not to book with a certain airline
because they think it's going to go bust
it will go bust
branson was fighting to keep virgin
atlantic alive and once again he put his
life on the line to do it he took off on
another dangerous promotional balloon
trip this one over the pacific
areas
in the middle of the pacific we lost two
full fuel tanks
and we didn't know we had enough fuel to
make it do we have any chance
we knew that we had to fly
this balloon at an average speed of over
180 miles an hour and that was just
blown by the wind and so the the chances
of that happening
were extraordinarily unlikely
but we got right into the core of the
jet stream and suddenly saw the
speedometer going 150 160 170 180 190
200 210 220
i'm not a religious person but it was as
if
somebody up there had just taken that
balloon and was just pushing it pushing
it through the jet stream
branson and lindstrand crash landed on a
frozen lake 300 miles from the nearest
habitation
we missed what we were aiming for by
three and a half thousand miles and
landed in the arctic in a snowstorm at
minus 60 degrees but we couldn't have
been happier in fact by the time branson
thought out he was a superstar
his record label was heating up too
virgin records signed janet jackson and
the rolling stones to multi-year deals
but in the short term it was irrelevant
british airways dirty tricks campaign
against virgin atlantic was making it
impossible to get credit to save the
airline branson had to make the toughest
call of his life
he decided to sell his beloved record
company penny pike served as his
personal assistant for 31 years everyone
was terribly
i mean richard was more shocked than
most people but he cried and cried and
cried
it was a bit like selling a child i told
the staff
burst into tears ran you know ran down
back towards my house with tears
streaming down my face you passed this
sign that said branson sells for a
billion dollars
and i realized life wasn't wasn't that
bad he secured the future of virgin
atlantic because he had enough capital
behind him after that to be able to look
any competitor in the face and say well
you know
i can you know i can sit this out as
long as you can people said at the time
we were mad to
you know sell the record company to put
the money into an airline as it turns
out of course the record industry's
collapsed and
the airline industry hasn't done too
badly for us one month after the billion
dollar label deal branson sued british
airways for libel
the airline settled out of court and
paid branson a record 1.1 million
dollars
we won the biggest libel damages of any
libel case
um and you know they had to make a
public apology
[Music]
oh richard branson was elated that day
was probably one of the great days of
his business career
he'd done it
he stomped on the mighty british airways
that night he was on the phone to
various people
and he had this real determination his
voice
that
this was the moment you know that he was
going to make virgin atlantic a global
success
and he was going to take this company
and grow it around the world
after selling virgin records for a
billion dollars in 1992 richard branson
was ready to exploit his most valuable
asset the virgin brand we suddenly
realized you know we actually have you
know something which is something we've
got to protect and we've got to nurture
the brand is
ultimately is what what virgin's all
about
branson was the brand and he tirelessly
promoted it
to date he has virginized over 300
products and services i think generally
if you can create something you can be
proud of
it's likely to be successful
i wasn't thinking
right let's just take this brand into
lots of different areas i just felt you
know we can we can we can do better in
health clubs we can do better in mobile
phone business
some ventures like virgin brides
and virgin cola
fizzled quickly
then the brand stumbled with virgin
trains
the acquisition came with a dilapidated
infrastructure and it took years to get
the trains to run on time
but some endeavors have been
breathtaking in their success
in 1999 branson struck paydirt he
partnered with service providers to
launch virgin mobile they supplied the
network he supplied the marketing and
name
and the innovative idea of letting
customers pay as they go
bert schmidt a professor at columbia
university's school of business is an
expert in branding
the value of a brand is really in the
intangibles because customers are not
just buying products they're not just
buying functionality they're also buying
an image they're buying a lifestyle
they're buying an experience he stands
for certain things he stands for service
for customer experience for innovation
for fun
branson was now business royalty
and was honored in 1999 by his country's
royalty
he was knighted by the queen as a
millennium icon for his contribution to
commerce
[Music]
becoming sir richard did nothing to slow
him down
five years later he took virgin mobile
public
with an ipo that he said valued the
company at 1.5 billion dollars
[Music]
branson made each of his new ventures an
independent company so that no single
failure could bring the empire down
nevertheless analysts have regularly
questioned the value of the virgin group
which is still privately held the
headlines would be you know when's
branson's balloon going to burst
and every time we started something new
you know stretching the brand too thin
and
and sometimes they went far off the
truth the virgin group continued to spin
off new ventures and in 2004 branson
announced one of his most imaginative
he was going to take people into outer
space beginning with his own mother i
think we're within about 18 months
of going up into space and then starting
a whole new area of commercial spaceship
travel hopefully hundreds if not
thousands of people will be able to have
the chance to become astronauts and go
into space
it's a huge risk
it's rather like putting your name your
brand on a formula one race car it's
great when it's winning but if it ends
up wrapped around a concrete pole
somewhere then then it has a lot of
downside
branson stretched the virgin brand even
farther in 2006
with his own airline spewing tons of co2
into the atmosphere he pledged to spend
all profits from his transportation
companies over the next 10 years an
estimated three billion dollars to fund
research for an eco-friendly biofuel
[Music]
he also launched the council of elders a
crisis intervention dream team led by
nelson mandela i'd reached the age of 55
i'd made
good money so i could pick up the phone
to pretty well anybody and cut through
and get things done suddenly i was in a
position where i could maybe make a
difference in the world
critics have scoffed at the new socially
minded branson and point to the offshore
tax shelters he has used for decades to
protect his wealth i don't think which
is any different to the other very very
wealthy businessmen who've got armies of
accountants and lawyers telling them we
know where to put their money where to
hide their money
is he the people's entrepreneur
only up to a point branson hasn't been
able to safeguard all of his assets
virgin america had a rough time getting
off the ground and lost nearly 400
million dollars before beginning to turn
a profit in the third quarter of 2010
[Music]
as he heads into his 60s it's been a
long and thrilling journey for the
virgin king
branson's made his own luck i think he's
been very very good at it
so it's not just a golden touch i think
he's worked for it of course he's driven
by money but he's not impressed by
wealth
he's more bothered but do i have fun and
don't have excitement
you got to have the balance
i've been extraordinary fortunate i've
enjoyed every minute of my life going
forward most of my time will be spent on
setting up not-for-profit enterprises
and seeing them in attacking some of the
big big problems in the world
um but at the same time you know we will
still have wonderful adventures
go go to space
go to the bottom of the oceans
and still push ourselves and challenge
my children and challenge the people
around me and
have a blast
he's the samurai warrior of silicon
valley
larry's attitude is if you want to
compete against me then be prepared to
be crushed
larry ellison started oracle software
over 30 years ago and it has made him
the highest paid executive over the last
decade with a total compensation of 1.84
billion dollars there was nobody better
than larry and making a customer believe
that he could change that person's
business life with his product
he sees around the corner well before
many of us get to the end of the street
he'll do whatever it takes to win in the
office
sap the german software firm was ordered
to pay oracle 1.3 billion dollars or on
the ocean there is absolutely no doubt
that he hates to lose
his company's technology has become the
backbone of the world's information
systems from government to online
commerce
the brazen billionaire is an ambitious
provocateur with a singular management
style i have a theory that larry's
succession plan for oracle is he is
trying to figure out a way that when
he's six feet under in a grave he can
still run oracle
loud and clear
okay
if you know anything about oracle's
larry ellison it probably goes something
like this i've got a bugatti the fastest
car in the world this home costs 200
million dollars the fastest sailboat
that's ever been built i'm addicted to
winning the more you win the more you
want to win he's a high flying
adrenaline junkie and an unapologetic
collector of expensive toys and real
estate
he spent 400 million dollars to bring
the 2010 america's cup the oldest active
trophy in sports back to america for the
first time in 15 years
[Applause]
but his success comes from something far
less flashy some of the world's most
essential software
tools you use every day but probably
don't realize that it's his company
making them work
[Music]
almost everybody in the world uses
oracle they just don't know it if you do
any kind of government transaction
with almost any government in the world
any business transaction with almost any
internet business in the world or any
traditional business if you have a
credit card if you have a cell phone if
you have any of the the modern things in
life if you live today i think you
probably use
oracle larry ellison arguably created
the most important computer software you
never heard of he was the man behind the
curtain for a tremendous change in the
way we all live ellison remained behind
that curtain when we tried to reach him
to participate in this program
born in the bronx in 1944 ellison grew
up in chicago when he was 12 his father
bluntly gave him some surprising news
my dad just said right before dinner oh
by the way you were adopted and we're
having meatloaf tonight it was so
shocking i just put it away and thought
about it
for years
without really you know confronting all
and realizing all of the implications he
dropped out of college twice ellison was
a mediocre student and disliked formal
education
mike wilson is an editor for the saint
petersburg times and interviewed ellison
extensively for his biography larry was
not interested in following the rules at
school in the family or anywhere else
larry needed to get out from underneath
the shadow of louis ellison and prove to
his father that he could make something
of himself his flair for the fast lane
was obvious early larry went out and
bought himself a turquoise blue
thunderbird he was a stylish guy he
wanted to impress people he got in that
car and he drove it to california
larry ellison was a young man with a
great deal of potential his trip to
california was
critical to who he would become
ellison settled in berkeley and set out
to make a living writing code
in 1973 he worked at the computer
electronics maker amdahl there he met
stuart fagan they've remained friends
for over 35 years
i went into my cubicle the first day i
worked there and across the hall were a
couple guys who never seemed to do any
work they just talked all the time and
one of them did nothing but talk about
himself how smart he was how stupid
everyone else was
and how he really ought to be running
everything and that was larry ellison
ellison was a talented but impatient
programmer desperate to find something
of his own to control
to say he he had the attention span of a
tumbleweed is to overestimate it i would
say more the attention span of a
lightning bolt
but his attention focused when he landed
a job at a company called ampex
ampex was struggling with a project
funded by of all places the
information-driven cia
the project was codenamed oracle
the cia needed a system to store and
retrieve vast amounts of foreign
intelligence concerned with its various
sensitive operations and missions
for ellison it was the job of a lifetime
and would plant the seeds for his future
in the 1970s information storage meant
putting data on reel to real tape which
was just too slow and inconsistent for
the cia and too slow for ellison
he left ampex and later started his own
company with his friend and programming
genius bob miner
bob and larry were a perfect odd couple
for silicon valley bob had all of the
engineering smarts the technical ability
larry on the other hand had the sales
ability the visionary ability the
ability to go to a customer and explain
here's how your business can change
with this original handwritten sign and
twelve hundred dollars they started
software development laboratories or sdl
ellison recruited friends at oates and
stuart fagan to help program he did want
me to join him uh and he's going to
start some kind of company and i thought
that was the stupidest idea i'd ever
heard because larry wasn't famous for
finishing things i used to say he's a
total flake and he'll never mount to
anything and i was half right
ellison's new company needed a product
and after reading an obscure ibm
research paper he thought he had it
a method of sorting information that was
vastly superior to anything that had
come before it was called a relational
database according to gary bloom who
worked with ellison for 14 years it was
a complex name but a simple idea
relational database what you know what
it what is it it's a collection of data
and information that's very simply put
into a format that makes it very easy to
search and find that information it's
nothing more complicated than that
ibm didn't see the potential of what
they had ellison did i said oh my god we
can beat ibm to market because ibm
doesn't believe in their own idea
ellison believed and asked programmer
bruce scott to start writing code
for me it's just cool technology and
kind of fun but for larry you know he
saw a company out of it he saw a market
out of it we weren't sure larry was
right but we needed the jobs
and it was a struggle all the time larry
was was
under a lot of pressure to get some
money in somehow in 1977 at age 34 larry
ellison's startup software company was
busy creating a smart database they
thought would revolutionize how
companies retrieve manage and analyze
data
three rooms and a little lobby area
there were four of us who were writing
programs larry was mostly involved in
finding customers
and that was a
bizarre idea because we had no software
so all the things that you would read in
books of somebody being a leader he
wasn't but he was tenacious he would
never give up on anything
ellison chased and cajoled customers
becoming the company's chief evangelist
there was nobody better than larry at
making a business person making a
customer believe that he could change
that person's business life with his
product
knowing they still needed a smarter
solution for the monumental task of
managing worldwide intelligence ellison
sold his database to the cia
his first customer
he called the new software oracle
version two there was no version one
because everyone thought
well no one buys version one it's buggy
so we started with version two well our
version two was at least as buggy as
anyone's version one and i described
those early versions as the roach motel
of databases the data went in but it
didn't come out
in 1982 ellison also took the name
oracle for his company he targeted
government agencies and major
corporations in his own unique way i
remember him telling me very distinctly
one time bruce we can't be successful
unless we lie to customers for some
reason larry told us the bank of america
i think he told us there were 15 of us
when in fact there were five of us i'm
not sure why the bank of america would
think differently of you if you're five
or fifteen
but larry had given them a number which
was a little larger than reality
ellison also was sharpening a sales
philosophy rooted in a trip he had taken
to japan in the early 1970s
i was in japan and i was talking to a
japanese business executive
and
he told me uh
you know that
the problem with america is that we just
have no stomach for competition
in japan we believe our competitors are
stealing the rice out of the mouths of
our you know of our children in japan we
think anything less than 100 market
share is not enough
his take no prisoners approach became
known as the oracle way the oracle way
in the early to mid 80s was just to win
almost by any means necessary
larry's attitude is if you want to
compete against me
then you better be prepared to be
crushed
or don't compete against me
his product the oracle database took off
like a jet fighter in one of his ads and
in 1986 oracle went public
his 39 stake in the company was worth a
stunning 93 million dollars the ipo was
a huge hit
but was overshadowed the very next day
by microsoft's public offering which
made bill gates stake worth a whopping
350 million dollars
in 1989 ellison moved oracle to this
mammoth campus in redwood shores
california which became known as the
emerald city a reference to the wizard
of oz or as one newspaper described it
larryland and everyone knew who was the
wizard when i ordered a ferrari 348 and
i was going to get the first 348 in
california
larry ordered one
from somewhere on the east coast and got
it shipped in before i got mine
he didn't want to be the second one he
wanted to be the first one
his obsession to be first took its toll
oracle hit a wall the these aggressive
sales practices started to cause serious
problems
oracle's aggressive sales practices in
the 80s turned the company into an
accountant's nightmare
the sales force was so aggressive so
willing to close a deal and there were
so few business controls over the makeup
of those deals then we started having
the problem of we certainly signed some
bad contracts
they were also selling products that
hadn't yet been created oracle was
selling a lot of futures
so you're taking a lot of money and a
lot of revenue in for future
deliverables
well then the question comes when you
finally have those deliverables now who
do you sell them to you already sold it
to everybody you sold it to them three
years before you had it
it didn't help the company's prospects
that their latest product was a dud
oracle version 6 was riddled with bugs
customers were frustrated and sales
plummeted
it's sometimes characterized as the
near-death experience of oracle in the
early 90s and it was we weren't cutting
fat we're cutting into muscle and you
might even say we're in a couple cases
we're cutting a couple limbs off
with oracle's stock price and free fall
so was ellison's personal fortune by
november 1st 1990 he had lost 790
million dollars
his company was nearly a billion-dollar
operation and it was failing
larry was trying to achieve this
greatness he was
building towards that all the time and
now
he was in a sense of laughing stock it
was devastating for him we're all a
bunch of kids that grew up with the
business
and we weren't kids anymore and the
business wasn't a little business
anymore it was big business and we had
to replace virtually all of senior
management and it was a very painful
process
he convinced well-known management and
sales consultant ray lane to join the
company
and what he brought was what i'd
characterize as operational discipline
and a maturity around this is how a big
business runs it was chaotic it was
painful
nobody wanted to go through that again
and so the culture was kind of reset
but the company's real savior came in
the form of a new product
zach nelson was oracle's youngest
marketing executive
oracle 7 was a spectacular product the
future was
incredibly bright
and i think everybody within oracle at
that time certainly knew it and could
sense it it wasn't just incrementally
better it was orders of magnitude better
ellison's company had dodged its
near-death experience
in 1994 oracle revenues passed the two
billion dollar mark and his stock as a
result was worth nearly three billion
dollars for ellison that wasn't nearly
enough to become software sole
heavyweight ellison knew he had to pick
a fight with the reigning champion bill
gates she seemed to be personally
disappointed he wasn't wealthier than
bill gates it's the scorecard and if you
weren't number one if you weren't racist
you weren't on the top you weren't the
best
it was the scorecard and he was losing
i think that larry thought he was in a
tremendous
competition with bill gates and and and
maybe gates didn't think so so much
larry wanted to be recognized as the
greatest innovator salesman evangelist
in the world of software and he had a
steep battle going up against the guy
who would put his software in every
single personal computer practically in
the world
[Music]
allison was fixated on gates he would
later admit publicly to hiring private
detectives to dig up dirt on him
gates new product windows 95 had the
entire tech world buzzing including
ellison himself in this appearance on
the charlie rose show
this windows 95 is an enormously
complicated piece of software and the
idea that people are going to install
this in their households and manage
these things their household to me is
hilarious and it's time for something
that's easier to use well this is
clearly part of our strategy to throw in
microsoft well the way it is around
microsoft is not somebody you know to
throw darts at bill gates and hate and
envy bill gates you have to think about
think about products and create products
that are better than the products that
microsoft is selling
ellison made a move into the consumer
device market
he called it the network computer or nc
he launched the network computer with
great fanfare the computers we currently
make personal computers are
rather expensive right very very complex
so we've introduced this new classic
computer and for normal human beings
that very little that's pretty very low
cost very lightweight now every person
can use a computer because they're low
cost and very easy to use
you can surf the net you can do email on
and he said and it's going to be 500
kind of an internet appliance so to
speak no different than your toaster i
can remember having a discussion with
him saying you know the internet makes
it possible to imagine
a world without
microsoft's operating system on every
desktop
and that was really you know the birth
of the nc ellison went on a campaign to
promote the power of his new baby on the
web while mocking the popular pc
i hate the pc with a passion put the
stuff on the net it's bits don't put
bits in cardboard cardboard and trucks
trucks to stores me yeah me go to the
store you know pick this stuff out it's
insane i love the internet
but falling pc prices meant the nc was
destined to fail
i don't think there was anything wrong
with the idea i actually just think it
was premature five years later would
have won the world and the only
difference is all the pc manufacturers
dell hp everybody else gateway what did
they do they created a 500 pc
that surfs the web really well
and it does email really well
and that shut down ellison's venture
into the consumer market
his nc was too far ahead of its time
but his vision of the internet was still
right on target
oracle's database became the
underpinnings of all of these internet
services that we take for granted today
expedia amazon ebay go down the list of
applications all of those are storing
all that information retrieving that
information delivering that information
doing those transactions through the
oracle database
people thought larry was crazy now
he's a genius kind of solved the biggest
i.t problem in history
by 2000 larry ellison's company oracle
was among the elite tech companies in
the world
but internal struggles would soon force
out the company's president and chief
operating officer ray lane who had risen
to second in command and heir apparent
he described the culture at the company
he left
it wasn't good enough for a salesman to
make their quota
they had to make 200 of their quota
it was
you know the top 10 percent get rewarded
millions
and everybody else
you know falls by the website their weak
soldiers shoot them
a departing lane said he didn't fit into
oracle's system and that the only person
making decisions at oracle is larry lots
of people that transitioned in and out
of oracle got confused who was in charge
and that's a pretty volatile that's like
a galactic collision
know where two stars hit and it's a
pretty violent explosion
oracle the company was on a roll but was
lagging behind in one key area we're
still fighting to be relevant in the
applications world we're the number two
application provider in the world and
we're number two in erp behind
sap boy this number two is getting old
and we're number two not for one we're
number two we're number two in uh crm
behind siebel but we're growing faster
than sap and we're growing faster than
siebel and we're determined to become
number one in applications as like we're
number one in database to get to number
one ellison needed to do something his
company had long avoided buying new
technology through acquisitions when he
came to that conclusion
he opened his wallet and bet bit far
bigger than anyone else did
and in fact he did it far faster than
anyone else did
ellison wanted to bundle new application
software with oracle's successful
product line
in 2003 he targeted the company
peoplesoft in a hostile takeover attempt
the department of justice sued oracle on
antitrust grounds charging the takeover
would empower the company to illegally
raise rates and impair innovation
after a year and a half long battle the
court sided with oracle ellison finally
acquired peoplesoft for 10.3 billion
dollars
it's very rare that someone gets sued by
the government and they actually win you
know i mean it's just another testament
to this guy's tenacity most guys would
have maybe walked away from that
instead ellison stepped it up over the
next five years he would spend close to
34 billion dollars acquiring 52
companies heather bellini is senior
managing director of the technology
research team at international strategy
and investment group she has covered
oracle since 2003. he started looking
out and seeing how the landscape was was
changing and how the carnage that was
done to some of his competitors was
going to give him an opportunity to
go make some acquisitions
and buy some technology where he was
behind
and he really was the one that started
the whole
m a trend within the technology industry
ellison's appetite for acquisitions
accelerated in 2009 with his 7.4 billion
dollar trophy purchase of the prominent
hardware company sun microsystems
but in 2010 his eyes were on another
trophy a decade-long 400 million dollar
obsession
bmw oracle racing was launched in 2000
for ellison's run at the americas cup it
may be the oldest active prize in
international sport but what ellison
created was entirely new
the boat is a trimaran
it often appears to be nearly flying
with only one of its three holes
actually in contact with the water
[Music]
the oceans have never seen anything like
it there is absolutely no doubt that he
hates to lose
there is no doubt of that at all grant
dalton has competed against ellison on
the americas cup circuit my recollection
and racing against him and we will race
against him in the future this is a man
that's very determined to win
on valentine's day 2010 ellison brought
the america's cup back to the united
states for the first time in 15 years
he celebrated with his now ex-wife
romance novelist melanie craft it was
his fourth marriage
the old samurai warrior reemerged when
his friend mark hurd resigned as ceo at
hewlett-packard amid allegations of
sexual harassment and expense account
irregularities
ellison was outraged he attacked the hp
board of directors
he said quote the hp board just made the
worst personnel decision since the
idiots on the apple board fired steve
jobs many years ago
exactly one month later alison stunned
the business world when he turned around
and hired the ousted executive
the silicon valley soap opera continued
when hp named leo apotaker as its chief
executive
his former company sap is oracle's
biggest rival in business software
sap and oracle had been locked in a
nasty three-year copyright infringement
case that ended in november 2010.
sap the german software firm was ordered
to pay oracle 1.3 billion dollars
it was the biggest settlement ever for
software piracy
larry ellison's brawl had drawn new
blood on the information technology
battlefield and as always he is more
determined than ever to win
larry ellison is
pretty similar to the new york yankees
they're the team you love to hate and as
a competitor to larry ellison i'm sure
he's the person
that people love to hate just given how
successful he's been
while most visionaries you think are
sort of just talking off their hat and
saying oh this is how the world can be
you know larry sees how the world can be
and then he actually tries to make it
that
[Music]
he started with a 1200 stake in a little
company and uh by sheer force of will
and persuasion he built it into one of
the giant software companies of the
world
you